[Music]  Nick Young singing a heartfelt Drake  song following his split from Iggy  Azalea the song is called redemption and  the NBA star posted the vid to Instagram  with the caption searching for these  words to say to you and towards the end  he runs into a door and seemingly yelled  the words bring her back but don't count  on a guy going back to her ex I love you  so much it now bunch of tight rapper  blames trust issues when she announced  their split on Instagram earlier this  month  quote unfortunately although I love Nick  and have tried and tried to rebuild my  trust in him it's become apparent in the  last few weeks I am unable to Nick was  implicated in a cheating scandal in  March 19 a pause but you won't be one  like what